welcome to the heavy spoiler show
i'm your host paul in this episode we're
breaking down one of the most
interesting aspects of the boys that is
stormfront
throughout this video we're going to be
going over everything you need to know
about her
including her true identity comic book
origins powers and more
obviously there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
check out the sixth episode of the
second season
then i highly recommend that you turn
off now make sure you drop a thumbs up
if you enjoy the video
and don't forget to subscribe to the
channel for breakdowns like this every
day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into stormfront
okay so those stormfront initially
seemed like some sort of social justice
warrior
that was always on a phone chatting to
idiots and boy do i do i know what that
feels like hey youtube
she's actually a far more complex
character that dates
all the way back to the start of the
20th century stormfront was born in
berlin in 1919
and though we don't know her actual name
i do have a theory that it's in fact
adele
in episode 6 we learn that the woman
she'd been claiming was her mother was
in fact called chloe
and with the name adele being of german
descent it does make sense that this
would actually be her own
it was also used as the password for her
computer which i doubt she would have
done
had her daughter actually been called
chloe now stormfront quickly became
swept up in the civil unrest that was
going on at the time in germany
and she became a member of the national
socialist party
aka the nazis their leader hitler was
obsessed with the aryan superman
a group of people apparently descended
from ancient norway
that he viewed as the master race hitler
wished to rule over the world
and supplant them as the true people of
the future and thus he hired frederick
ward to begin work on a super soldier
program
that would create people with
extraordinary abilities
stormfront married vote and we
discovered that she was actually given
the first ever successful compound v
injection which granted her incredible
powers
stormfront is actually trying to
replicate this procedure and though we
don't offer definite yet
i do believe that this holds the key to
her immortality
in episode 6 we learned that babies
injected with v
take to it quite well whereas adults do
not the fact that we know the seven were
young children that have aged normally
whereas stormfront hasn't i think ties
into her receiving
v in adulthood it is possible that if
you have it when you already matured
that you don't age at all but either way
stormfront has lived through the last
century
barely changing at all why she left
germany is unknown at this point
but if we look at the comic books namely
her counterpart
in that he fled the country during the
war and ended up in america
working for a vote program named payback
payback is pretty much the
avengers whereas the seven is the
justice league now the stonefront wasn't
really present in the war he still
clearly carried the ideals that he was
brought up with
and they remain in him even after all
the social change that humanity went
through over the past 50 years or so
now in the show stormfront became
liberty and throughout the 70s she
operated throughout the deep south
after stopping a civilian and murdering
them because they were black
liberty faded into obscurity and was
likely hidden away by vort who wanted to
brush this dirty little secret under the
rug
they even paid the only eyewitness of
and liberty was quickly forgotten about
as new heroes were brought into the
limelight now most heroes would have
just been cast to the side
however it's likely because of
stormfront's connection to wart
that she was looked after by the
corporation we do know that
at some point stormfront was a member of
the church of the collective
however she left after they started
letting people in that she viewed as
undesirable
after the death of translucent
stormfront was brought in by vaught's
ceo stan edgar
and she quickly gained a mass following
of people due to her edgy posts and
memes
it seems like she's trying to manipulate
these fans known as storm chasers
to create enough public out raw so that
she can launch her true plan
which is to create an army of
superpowered people to rule over the
world with
initially she started off by publicly
ruining homeland his image
however she's come around recently and
is likely just using him
for more than lasering her tits now i
actually believe that she wishes to have
a child with him
and that she's purposely trying to get
pregnant in order to not only have a son
but also have it as something that she
can use to control him
stormfront is very high up in vort and
because of this
she's likely aware of what's going on
with his son ryan and becca
through their relationship she will have
seen that no matter what
he won't kill becca and i think she's
trying to get things in place so that
if it ever comes down to it he won't
kill her either
homelander is probably the only person
that ever could
and it's a really smart move by the
character now on top of this
homelander possesses many of the
character traits that she looks for
he's pretty much the embodiment of the
aryan superman
and if she wishes to truly create a
master race it makes sense to have a
child in the vein of the villain
now as for her powers she actually
possesses quite a lot
as i'm sure you know we'll make all
their soups in a lab
but they give them comic book like
backstories to make it seem like they're
heroes
stormfront is actually supposed to be a
nordic god which not only ties back to
the aryan race
but it's also meant to riff on thor from
the avengers stoneprint is able to
manipulate plasma
and she can charge molecules with
electricity in order to fire out
electrical blasts
these powerful attacks make her almost
unstoppable and not only do they blast
those hit with them backwards
they also incapacitate the target for a
while
stormfront can also fly and with this
she's able to move through the air at
mach3 speeds
in addition to this she's super durable
and is capable of withstanding all types
of damage
the character also possesses a healing
factor that means she can recover from
any wound quite quickly
so lasera bloody tatsuya now to top it
off
she has incredible superhuman strength
that means she's able to move through
objects with ease
in episode three of season two she
completely devastates an apartment
complex in minutes
blasting through the walls and killing
most of the people that she comes across
without prejudice
well it was pretty prejudiced to be fair
now as mentioned earlier
she's also almost immortal and at this
point we don't know whether she ages or
not
if she was born in 1919 then that makes
her
two seconds wait it's it's 20 20 now in
1990 carry the 101 years old
now with all this combined she's
probably the most powerful in the seven
i really hope that it comes down to a
battle with her and homelander
however cindy is also a wild card too
it does seem like cindy was the one used
to kill rainer due to her abilities that
we see her demonstrate in episode 6.
stormfront has clearly been using her to
tidy up her dirty work
and i think it would be brilliant to see
the two go head to head
now as for the comics stormfront follows
a pretty similar path
but instead of being married to vort he
was part of the hitler youth program
he fled to america and vo actually
reused some of his dna
for the other supes homelander in some
ways is actually cloned from stormfront
which if they carry this across to the
show it's gonna make that sex scene
even even weirder oh i don't know if
they will do this but
as she is the first ever soup who knows
at this point
it's not it's not like homelander isn't
a complete weirdo anyway
and from what i've seen of the guy he
might even like being with himself
but how did the character die in the
comics well
stormfront was a big baddie in the
source material and he was actually
taken out by the boys
after they wiped out payback the group
hunted him down and managed to kill him
by basically clubbering his head in and
then stamping on his balls
ouch i'm not sure if this will be
carried over to the show
especially the balls part but i think
the character definitely deserves a
really gory death as let's face it
she's pretty much the worst person ever
she makes homelander look like clark
kent
and lex luthor look like like someone
good
i don't know where this is going no
whether she will survive this season or
not remains to be seen
but it's clear that the character will
do anything to remake the world in her
image
it's a scary thought and hopefully this
video has given you everything that you
need to know about it
if there's any major updates i might do
another video down the line discussing
her
but thanks for bearing with me as we
gave you the 4-1-1
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on stormfront so make sure you
comment below and let me know
if you enjoyed this video then please
drop a thumbs up and make sure you check
out our breakdown of homelander which is
going to be linked at the end
we go over everything you need to know
about the hero well villain
so definitely check it out after this
we're also giving away a free copy of
the christopher nolan collection
and all you have to do to be with the
chance of winning is like the video
subscribe to the channel and drop a
comment below the win is going to be
chosen at random on the 30th of
september
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter thanks for
making it until the end of the video
you've been the best i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you